so tell me about your
teeth these your these are gold or
diamonds what are those gold and
diamonds gold and diamonds fully flooded
diamonds you know what I'm saying all
your teeth are diamonds and gold yes
what that cost you $20,000 20,000 yes
roughly $220,000 yes ask the Jeweler do
money is it her to eat uh I can take
them out you brush your teeth yeah I
brush my teeth hell yeah I brush my
brush my grill and my teeth you know I
gotta brush both you
know look at that
all right King
script script uh where you from
originally where' you grow up I grew up
in South Central Los Angeles no couple
two blocks away from fig street is that
right yeah so you saw this growing up
yeah I seen a whole lot growing up how
old are you now I'm 26 26 tell me about
your family growing
up my family grew up in the house you
know big house a lot of kids you know
brothers sisters you know everybody in
the house you know doing their own thing
you know I'm outside in the streets you
know we all doing our own thing like I
said you know yeah you had Mom and Dad
yeah POS moved away you know uh around
the time I was nine you feel me but
Mom's uh been there the whole time you
know shout out to moms what did your dad
do for work uh he was he worked for like
Dale computers you know building
computers and like that see had a
good job yeah rest peace pops but you
took to the streets yeah I went to the
streets what was attractive about
that the streets the streets was like it
was like a fast life you know it was
like I was out there and the girls the
money everything it was just cool you
know so I decided to you know lead
towards that way and with the girls and
the money the party life you
know has it been good to you it was good
to me how many years you been doing it
uh I did it for about 9 years N9 years
mhm and you're how old Now 26
26 how heard you in
school I did I got a high school diploma
that's about it I ain't got nothing else
after that you know I could have went to
college but I wanted to do something
else you know Steer something
different tell me about the the pimp
game so what what is it that a pimp
offer as a
girl
so my point of view of what a pimp
offers a girl is like you know guidance
instruction you know and keep her away
from self-destruction you know basically
like you know it's a thing called
Renegades you know what I'm saying and
renegades is a big thing out here yeah
those girls without pimp you know doing
their thing on their own you know trying
to uh get the money on their own and all
that but you know it don't really
work for them all the time you know
there is some successful Renegades
though don't get it wrong but you know
it don't work for everybody you know
what I'm saying like y'all got problems
with yall run into with tricks you know
and that's where you know your folks
come in at your pimp you know what I'm
saying like you know they can help you
with all that you know instruction on
like when yall moving around the United
States they don't know what to do you
know they they don't know how to do this
how to get money here how to do it there
it's just they just going places
thinking that it can work and it's
failing for them you know so that's what
uh the pimp position is really you know
to help the out you
know
did anybody teach you this this game
when you no nobody taught me nothing I I
I learned everything on my own like I
literally just learn from buming my head
and burning my hands learning the fire
is hot you know saying you made what
kind of mistakes have I made I say early
on growing up and into this game made
mistakes
like just start off playing with the
game you know what I'm saying I started
out playing you know thinking that you
know this something that you know that
can you know just be cool to do and
everything you know but when I start
getting in trouble and you know I
start realizing like okay this ain't
going to work here and that ain't going
to work here you feel me this know you
ain't going to be able to get your money
the proper way the way you expect it to
come in when you up in other
areas you know what I'm saying so when
you got these great areas then you know
it go bad on you all the time and
that's why I up at in them great
areas you know what I'm saying and I had
to you know make myself better through
that you've done some prison time yeah I
did prison time you know uh I went down
for human trafficking and pimping and um
um I fought a case for that how many
years I did three years three years yeah
three years total took about five with
half did a little bit more um you know
but uh other than that it was like that
case there was like let me
see long story short it was a that
told on me you know what I'm saying I
only had the two days and was them
near fighting my whole life behind this
you feel me so it was like you
know that was something I had to learn
my lesson from too like you know another
gray area in in the game you know
luckily through Instagram you know and
messages and everything that's what
saved me and got me out the whole life
pickled you know the uh the gangs are a
big part of the that that neighborhood
down there yeah the gangs is a big part
of it now one thing about me I never got
involved into the gangs you know I got
involved into the streets you know like
of getting money you're not a or
blood or no I'm not a or a blood or
Hoover none of
that I was just you know addict to money
what what what kind of girls does a pimp
look for down there ones that want money
ones that want to go get the money it's
all about the money you know and then
there it's like
today everybody want to be a pimp
everybody want to be a hoe you know what
I'm saying it's not made for everybody
but everybody doing it though you know
what I'm saying so it's
like it's it's nether air there you know
yeah more than any field I've ever seen
the pimp pimps can range from totally
respectable and honorable and trying to
be helpful for a girl who's who's in the
streets to the worst you can imagine and
that's where you got the three different
types of pimps what are the three
different kinds you got the Romeo pimp
you got the gorilla pimp then you got
the Finesse pimp now three different
ones I know yall want to know the Romeo
pimp is like the boyfriend pimp that's
when everybody you know it's like most
popular now you know what I'm saying
it's a lot of boyfriend pimps going on
you know that comes in from like you
know gang members and you know other
people that just really don't know what
they doing girls the Renegades turning
guys out you feel me because need
protection so you feel me like they got
them you know what I'm saying these
their boyfriends you feel me and these
be the type of that be ready to
kill behind their you feel me so
that's the boyfriend pimp you know just
to make the long story short on that
then you got the Finesse pimps those are
the ones who finesse with their mouth
their words you feel me in the game you
know what I'm saying like it ain't it
ain't nothing more nothing less to it
you know they got a game you feel me
just give it to them then you got the
gorilla pin the gorilla pin pin by force
you know what I'm saying Pinn by force
they hand they put they you know what
I'm saying it's like is just just
get my money or you going to get beat
the up you know what I'm saying
simple that's that what what what's the
most girls that you've had at one time
oh the most I had at one time was 10 10
yes so that's got to be insane yeah it
was it was stressful it was stressful I
didn't like it at all you didn't like it
N I didn't like I wouldn't I would never
do nothing like that again 10
n so so Pimp's job is is to collect the
money at the end of the night or after
every trick
[Music]
it depend on how they want to do it
honestly I just seen it all done in all
kind of different ways you know I'm
saying I seen I hav seen everybody break
as they go like you know get their money
each trick I didn't seen them get their
money after every night you know I'm
saying it just depend on you know the
person you know it depends on the person
that's collecting the money you feel me
on how they feel you know how much money
they got on like you know they wealth
that they already in and the girls give
you all their
money yeah they supposed to give they
they supposed to get the pimp all their
money
yeah but some some some girls are
holding on to some of it trying to
that's called tucking that's called
tucking right there that's what they not
supposed to do when they tuck their
money that's when they gorilla pimps get
to kicking in you sh you have to like
inspect them just to make sure there's
nothing hidden
in it just depend on the person wig in
their shoe in their wherever it depend
on the person you know cuz like some
people they not they blind tall that you
know they're not really you know hip to
the girls tucking on them and stuff you
feel me you trust your girls me if I
with a I'mma trust them you
know I got to trust them you feel me and
if I can't trust you then it's like you
know I either keep you on the back end
or I just can't with you straight
up and tell me about drugs in this game
drugs up the game a whole lot
drugs up a whole lot you know do
you do anything other than the pot that
you're smoking I smoke weed you know I
with ecstasy here and there there
you know what I'm saying but you know
that's that's about it but the girls
sometimes you getting girls on crack or
I done got girls on all kind of
different but I ain't never had
girl on crack I don't know if they've
been on crystal I really don't know cuz
I had girls on some quick you feel
me like here for a couple days and they
gone and I was like what the is
wrong with them I don't know but as far
as crack and all the hard drugs and
I really don't know but the biggest
thing I know out there right now taking
over the streets is per heads per Tak f
on it right the 30s 30s have fed on in
it yet yeah
that's a bad one that's bad that's bad
so the cops are pretty pretty easy on
you guys right on the girls at
least cops ain't easy on nobody no I'll
say that cops ain't easy on nobody I see
them rolling by and there there'll be
there'll be 10 girls out on the street
corner and they're just cruising by well
it's just you know they it's a popular
area they know what's going on it's a
popular area that that that place been
around longer than we've been around
longer than you know you've been around
it's been it's going to be there after
us you know what I'm saying and know
they know that you know so it's not
really too much they can do to stop
what's going on out there like they
going to have to arrest every girl and
then what it's not like it's really
against the law where they can send
every girl to prison behind that so
it's not going to prisons aren't big
enough for that many girls it's big
enough but they just know the the laws
ain't you know strict enough with all
that M no did you did you ever think of
that you'd be doing something other than
this in your life you
yeah now I got a business you know you
know I start I start you know working
into a business so you know I got other
going on most definitely what would
you like to be doing in 10 years five
years I plan on be on top of my business
my funeral business you know so if y'all
know any anybody that's dying around
y'all you know what I'm saying that you
know y needs funeral services you know
know I got that going you know what I'm
saying Prestige Funeral Home you know
what I'm saying look us up is that right
yep that's that interesting combination
of careers of
hustles that's about my only one right
now what what do your parents think of
what you're doing my father rest in
peace you know he just died about a year
ago and uh my mom what she think about
what I was doing is like she didn't like
it but she had to accept it because she
knew I was going to do what I was going
to do anyway you know what I'm saying so
it was
like just be safe you know don't don't
get hurt you know don't don't
just know I love my son you feel me I
don't want nothing happening to you type
you know what I'm saying how do how
do you view what a pimp does I mean like
a pimp is uh you know some people say
you're just taking advantage of these
girls they're doing all the work and
giving you all the money I feel like
that's when it comes down to the three
different types and you know what
I'm saying the ones that's doing their
job the right way who is giving the
instructions and leading the girls to
you know be better about their self you
feel me doing the right thing you know
like I feel like those are the ones
that's like they they keeping the game
good but then you got the people that's
you know that messed the game up and
those are the boyfriends and the
gorillas you know that's beating the
out the game and you know
mentally these into
other you know so when they go
with somebody that's real you know what
I'm saying they thinking some whole
other is different you
know it's it's such a such a seedy
hustle that uh that you're involved
in you know every everybody's
like seems like everyone's dishonest
whether it's the tricks the girls The
Pimps everybody's got some crazy hustle
and and no one can trust
anybody it's got to be a hard life to
just go through day by day right yeah
it's hard to trust anybody in the game
it's hard to trust anybody for sure you
can't trust the tricks some of these
know a lot of can't
trust their folks you know and these
can't trust their so you
know I done been through a lot and been
robbed by my you feel me you have yes
what's the craziest thing you've seen
craziest thing I've seen as far is what
like in your nine years on in the
game man I seen a lot I don't know I I
don't even know where to start I didn't
had I I didn't seen get
kidnapped you know what I'm saying but
you know they didn't came back you feel
me you know and and I didn't seen I
didn't seen die in the game I
didn't I didn't seen all kind of
you know I didn't see all kind of wild
I mean is is is a girl
are you are you cool with a girl like
relieving a a trick of his wallet or his
phone or his watch or whatever when uh
when they're in the hotel room or the in
the car whatever they're doing a date to
say right now no but then at the time I
love it I love it cuz it's really just
about making money I love it it's all
about the money you know what I'm saying
the tricks they love giving their money
away the girls love collecting the money
and giving away to their daddy and Daddy
love collecting the money you know what
I'm saying it's a combination cycle you
feel me just keep going from there you
know is there a romant romantic aspect
to this yeah thing for you yeah the
way like you got to like you got to have
love for your you feel me like
these out there risking their
life for you like I said got kidna
and Di behind this you feel
me so like I feel like a a pimp sh
love for they ho you know what I'm
saying in general you feel me because if
they out there risking their life for
you they bring up all they money back to
you Faithfully then it's like you know
what more is there to know not love this
you feel me like ain't nobody else
going to do that for you you know
like ain't nobody else they they not
going to go out there go walk them
streets and be out there cold and you
know what I'm saying bringing that
back to you feel me so you got that's
some something you got to appreciate you
know where where do you stay do you have
a place to sleep at night yeah I stay
right now in Vegas you stay in Vegas
yes and the girls are staying where in
this motel rooms I don't have any girls
right now as far as we're talking as far
as right now I have any girls got it got
to cover your
ass gotta cover that ass you know yeah I
understand wa what's how are Vegas and
Los and Los Angeles
different Vegas is a 24hour city La is
like 24 hours in certain places you know
what I'm saying like you got to know
where to go you know what I'm saying
got to know where to go and and when
it's 24 hours in La it's the streets 24
hours in Vegas you got the casinos you
got you got everything stores is open
they sell liquor 24 hours is different
you know so it's a it's a surv they got
the clubs all that where do you
make more
money it depends on where they at I mean
it depends on the girl it depends on the
location and how like like the time they
put into it it depends on all that cuz
you know you can be out here they can be
on fig making a th000 to 2,000 a day
they can be in Vegas making you know
2,000 to whatever a day you know what
I'm saying it's it's whatever like it's
the sky is the limit have you seen
certain girls that just are really good
money
makers I just see some girls that make
good money I just see some that
don't make no money what what's the
secret to being successful on that to be
successful and making money for a
stay on your hustle don't be lazy
it's not going to come to you you got to
get on your grind you know what what's
the hardest part of this job for a for
for a
Pimp dealing with these
dealing with these for
real that is mentally disturbing
but you
know it's it's it's uh it's for the best
of us what do you do when they get out
of
line like what what would I
do now what would I
do hypothetically
speaking it depends on the situation now
like know like you
get nah I don't do that I don't put my
hands on
I don't do
that but now as far as like know
punishment goes I'll say
like you just got to like put them in
their place you feel me like it don't
even got to always be putting your
putting your hands on them but if you
feel like they pushing there they
pushing that then you don't need them
you know what I'm saying just get rid of
them and then when you get rid of them
they see that it's that real like damn
like he a good niggaer you feel me he a
got to put his hands on me they might
want to come back you feel me so like
that's the whole part of the Finesse you
know what I'm
saying you have
kids yeah I got a son 8 years
old he's with
Mom he with my
mom I'm sorry he with my mom he's with
your mom
mhm where's his
mom she live out here somewhere I read
don't know we don't like really have
contact with her like that you know what
I'm saying but you know she's somewhere
out
here in script what what would you say
is the most important lesson you've
learned in your life in my life your 26
years can't trust
nobody can't trust nobody you've been in
the game too long been in the game way
too long to trust anybody you can have
trust for people but you can't like you
know don't really put your all in it you
feel me cuz you'll be blinded when they
see that you got your all in them you'll
be blinded they like they'll trick you
you know what I'm saying like they'll be
like okay he trust everything I do type
or you know what I'm saying
whatever it's anybody a girl
family anybody you know what I'm saying
they cross you cuz they feel like you
know you putting your all into
them you've had black girls white girls
Mexican girls I had the ball got out of
ball what's what's are certain girls
easier than other certain
races that's the that's like a big thing
right now going on to the blacks the
other races and all that other I
love them all you know what I'm saying I
love them all you know I love all the
girls that like to get money you know
what I'm saying but
um who makes the best
money honestly it's like a big fight in
that you know we all know the whites and
Mexicans the Asians they going to make
more money you know what I'm saying
standing on the streets and because
it's like not really a racial thing but
y'all got to think about it you know the
tricks that's out there they white
Mexican and Asian and they're not
really black like it's black tricks out
there but ain't nobody really giving
them no love you know what I'm saying so
majority of them is Mexican white and
Asian so if you think about it in the
natural life you know a white person
Asian person mexic person black person
they like they own race you know what
I'm saying that's what they like so when
they out there on the streets and they
see they own race and it's something
that they like that's what they going to
spend their money on so these Mexican
girls and white girls that's why they
make more money because that's their
tricks out there you get what I'm saying
and the black girls is more like a
fantasy to them because they like you
know it's different but you know you got
some also that like really like these
black girls you feel me so you know it
it's different you feel me it's like a
big you know argument in that you know
what I'm saying and you know I don't
really be too judgmental I've heard a
lot of the black girls tell me that they
won't date black guys yeah they the
white girls will yeah so that opens up a
larger market for them mhm the black
guys treat the white girls better
I mean then they do the black girls
black guys treat treat girls however
they going to treat them honestly they
they tricks too just like everybody else
it's just they more so you know crafty
you know they more so crafty you never
know what's going know what it's going
to be with them more games yeah it's
like you know they can they can just you
know switch up at any time so it's like
you
know all right script thank you so much
for sharing your
story wish you lots of luck out here in
LA appr appreciate it stay out of
trouble for sure okay man thank
you